don't make a plan that is what you
should do make a plan that outlines a
future so that you can sit back and say
look if I had that future then all the
horrible things that are going to happen
to me are going to be worthwhile that's
what you want if you want to think this
game is worth playing despite its
tragedy that's what you've got in life
enough meaning to serve as an antidote
to tragedy and then you generate a
strategy the other thing you should do
if you're not very industrious is
discipline yourself eat three times a
day at regular meal times that's a good
thing to practice because that starts to
put some stability into your life get up
at the same time I would highly
recommend all those young people out
there who are listening you want to get
a jump on life get the hell out of bed
in the morning as I've got older I've
got up earlier and earlier now that's
partly because you don't need as much
sleep but it's also partly because I've
got more and more discipline get up
early in the morning and get your things
done learn to get up at six in the
morning and you'll be one deadly
creature especially if you can get to
work you'll have half your damn day done
and so that's a massive massive
Advantage need motivation watch a top 10
with believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I'm these videos because
you are probably the most ambitious
person in your circle but you know
you're capable of more and you get that
Push by surrounding yourself with the
best so today this one from one of the
best Jordan Peterson and my take on his
top 10 was a success Joy
look Will Ferrell Warren Farrell not the
comedian Warren Farrell the author he
outlined data in why men earn more which
is a book I would recommend by the way
showing that if you work 13 longer hours
you make 40 percent more money
it's non-linear so you think why is that
well imagine you had 10 employees and
one of them Works an extra 10 percent
it's not much well how often is that
person going to be
promoted assuming you have a clue as a
boss it's like you're going to look at
the 10 people and you're going to think
oh that guy's always here like 45
minutes early it's like why don't we
give him the promotion obviously right
so these tie these small edges that you
can manage like that work an extra 10 or
extra 13 have non-proportional payoffs
that's part of the Pareto distribution
so
get
get your sleep cycle organized so you
get up in the morning learn how to do it
no excuses I'm too tired in the morning
I don't like mornings who cares that's
not relevant it's like discipline
yourself so you can manage it
schedule your meals because that's a
good disciplinary routine
and then learn to use a calendar like
Google Calendar most of you many of you
out there do not use a calendar okay a
calendar is not a prison and it's not a
tyrant not if you use it properly
a calendar keeps anxiety at Bay it makes
sure that you do what you need to do
which is important because otherwise you
fall behind but if you use it properly
though it's also helps you plan what you
want to do so I could say well lay out
your damn calendar
and design the days you would like to
have that's what your calendars have is
for so you can put in all sorts of
things in there you want to do and that
would be good for you and that's a
really good a really good way to start
being more industrious make a plan you
need a plan for three years
you need a plan for the next year you
need to plan for the next six months you
need to plan for the next three months
you need a plan for the week you need a
plan for the day you need to plan for
the hour all of that all of that I make
lists constantly of what I have to do
and they're like daily weekly monthly
yearly right now I can't look out more
than about six months you know because
my life is too complicated and chaotic
but but you need a vision of who you
could be what character you could have
three to five years out you can't go
much farther than that because life is
too unpredictable I think to make Vision
that's longer term than that
subject to
there's too much chance associated with
it to spend a lot of time on maybe you
can stretch it to five years and in rare
cases you can have a 10-year goal but it
has to be pretty low resolution but you
want plans at all those levels of
resolution you want to write the things
down and what because what are you going
to do you're going to stumble around and
get get what you need you're going to
stumble around and be useful to other
people and it's useful to be useful to
other people you know they want to work
with you then they want to do things
with you they want to have you around
they trust you they open up
opportunities for you and if you stumble
around like you're blind you're not
going to get anywhere and then you're
going to suffer and then you're going to
be bitter and then you're going to be
cruel so that's a bit that's hell that's
a bad outcome so unless you want that
don't aim for it and or or aim for the
opposite because that's how you get out
of it rule number two use your freedom
of speech so I would say well without
Free Speech there's no true thought and
then you might say well who the hell
cares whether or not we think and I
think the answer to that is fairly
straightforward I mean you might think
it's so obvious that it doesn't need
explanation but there are very few
things that are so obvious they don't
need explanation so the reason you think
is so that the world doesn't smack you
as hard as it might fundamentally you
know and I really mean this technically
because the way that people evolve the
capacity to thought for thought was that
the prefrontal cortex which mediates a
lot of of voluntary linguistic ability
actually emerged over the course of
evolutionary history out of the motor
cortex and so that's a very interesting
thing to understand because it means
that you know animals basically think by
moving and the problem with that is if
you think by moving and you make the
wrong move then you're dead whereas what
human beings can do is they can generate
fictional avatars of themselves in
fictional worlds and they can run the
avatars as simulations and the ones that
get killed they don't Express in
behavior and I mean you can do that with
words too although people you know
originally would have done it mostly
with images they do the same thing with
drama and so the reason reason that you
think and I think it was George was it
Alfred North Whitehead that said this I
think but I'm not absolutely sure the
reason you think is so that your
thoughts can die instead of you and
that's a Brilliance it's a brilliant
brilliant phrase and and absolutely the
case so if you think properly then you
kill off the ideas that if you acted out
would kill you or at least cause you
suffering or perhaps cause suffering to
the people around you and since it's
more or less obvious a priori that
suffering is worse than not suffering
under most circumstances it seems
reasonable to act in a manner that will
minimize it to the degree that that's
possible and so you need Clarity of
thought because that helps guide you
through a world that's enshrouded in fog
and full of sharp objects and if you
don't want to stumble into them and
impale yourself then you should have
sharp vision and sharp capacity to
communicate you know that's one of the
things I tell students when I'm trying
to teach them to write because they no
one ever tells them why they should
learn to write it's like you learn to
write so you can think and you learn to
think so that the world doesn't treat
you any more harshly than it absolutely
has to and that's no joke you know and
if you if you're a person who's been
around a bit you see very rapidly that
people who sharpen their arguments
properly and can articulate their
position and defend it are always always
the people who are most successful and
most compelling and that and that change
the way structures function and and that
also help things continue in the proper
path when they're running down the
proper path it's no joke to be
articulate and to be able to think there
isn't anything that's more powerful than
that
and that's a good segue into the second
or the third part of what I wanted to
talk to you about
see
since I made those videos uh I've become
I guess the word is popular
on yeah well in many ways by about
November by the end of November last
year there were more than 200 newspaper
articles about the consequences of the
videos that I produced and I and those
were like in press printed articles I'm
not talking about anything that happened
on YouTube and YouTube is a very strange
phenomenon let me tell you it's a far
more powerful than you think so just as
an aside I was on a program last week
hosted by a guy named Joe Rogan I don't
know how many of you know who Joe Rogan
is Joe Rogan gets 1.2 billion downloads
of his podcasts a year is think about
that like that's absolutely unparalleled
and everybody under 30 is getting their
news from either Facebook or from
YouTube and the whole conventional media
sources their debt is they're so dead
you can hardly believe it so YouTube and
one of the reasons I'm bringing it up is
because YouTube is the first platform
that's produced for people the capacity
to make the spoken word as far-reaching
and permanent as the written word right
that's a complete cultural revolution
it's the first time it's ever happened I
mean it wouldn't have to be YouTube it
just turns out that that's the platform
that got there first but it's a big deal
and anyways
um
the re the reason that that that my that
I became popular I think was partly
because of the of the political
philosophical videos that I made but
then when people came to my website to
watch them they stayed generally
speaking to watch the lectures that I
had been posting on there since 2013 and
uh
those were derived from work I did on a
book called maps of meaning which I
published in 1999 and you see what I was
trying to do with that book was to sort
something out that was very complex and
that was
when I was growing up and the cold war
was raging
I I couldn't understand precisely why we
had divided into two armed camps around
our respective ideological positions
either why those ideological positions
were so important that people would risk
the destruction of the world to protect
them let's say or why it was those two
particular ideologies or whether or not
this was just a difference of opinion
right which would be that would be a
more post-modern view is there's
multiple ways that you can organize
Societies in the west we happen to
organize our society one way but that's
one of a plethora of potential ways of
organizing society and let's say the
Communists had decided to organize their
society another way and human beings are
infinitely malleable and so you know the
social structures that we occupy are
arbitrary in some sense and matter of
opinion and maybe Collective opinion but
nonetheless still a matter of opinion
and I thought well is it the case that
the values that we hold to be true in
the west are merely based upon opinion
and so I started to investigate that and
and
the conclusion that I came to as a
consequence of hitting the question from
multiple different perspectives was that
that was not a reasonable way of
formulating of of of interpreting the
evidence and so I looked at neuros
evidence from neuropsychology and
Neuroscience mostly mostly uh
based at least in part on the work of
someone named Jeffrey gray it was a very
good psychologist very interested in
anxiety I looked at
General behavioral psychology looked at
literature and I looked at mythology
and I could see a pattern emerging
across all of those which I think is a
nice way of determining whether or not
something exists like it's one thing to
see a pattern in one set of data but if
you can see the same pattern in another
set that's quite historically distinct
from the first and then see the same
pattern in another set and then another
set then the probability that that's a
spurious pattern starts to decrease
quite radically rule number three don't
underestimate others you never want to
underestimate
the people that you're at war with
that's a big mistake
they're and I see no evidence at all for
a clinical Psychopathology on Putin's
side I mean he's
Russians are complicated and he's
complicated he is by no means the worst
leader that Russia's had in the last
hundred years not by any stretch of the
imagination I'm not standing up for
Putin but I'm not going to casually
demonize him
you can't take your simplistic
understanding of Adolf Hitler or Joseph
Stalin which is incomplete and then say
well that's Putin it's like look we're
in trouble here
Wars tend to spread and everyone thought
when the first world war started yeah
I'd be a few months and then when it
wasn't they thought well we'll win
easily it's like no that isn't what's
going to happen and the people thought
the same thing in World War II and they
thought the same thing in Afghanistan
and so
this is a localized Ukraine Russia
conflict well first of all no it's not
it's a war by proxy of Russia against
the entire West obviously now all the
world isn't on board with that but much
of the world is but not all of it and so
you know you might say when your sleeve
gets caught in an industrial machine and
only an inch of your sleeve is in you
think well I've still got my whole arm
it's like yeah for the next 10 minutes
but don't be thinking that that's how
it's going to be in half an hour and
it'll be an absolute bloody miracle if
this doesn't engulf us all
and there's a high probability of that
with all of that all that that entails
what would it mean for the Russians to
lose
like let's say that's what the West
wants we want Russia to lose okay well
what do you mean by that lose exactly do
you want the Russians to feel
that they're going to lose
they have atom bombs
what is going to happen to a country
that's already paranoid and misguided
if they also think they're going to lose
you think they're just going to lose and
we're not going to lose along with them
that's not going to happen
and so we're playing with fire on and I
think I'm I've written an article
uh called the Civil War in the west
because I think what's happening in
Russia and Ukraine is
a civil war in the west it's just that's
just where it started
Russia's the West
and it's not just about post-soviet
territorial expansion it's not just
about oil and gas it's definitely about
those things but it's about way more
it's about the stunning blindness and
stupidity of Europe on the energy front
who didn't know this was going to happen
do you who's so blind that they believed
that making Europe dependent on Russian
oil and gas
for environmental reasons wasn't going
to produce this
and while we didn't know well if you
were a Statesman and you didn't know
that you are so incompetent that it
defies comprehension because that's so
self-evident and so now we're in that
situation rule number four turn chaos
into order how do you frame that how do
you take that emergent chaos and make
habitable order out of it you don't know
is the whole capitalist system rotten to
the core I mean that's a convenient
explanation under those circumstances
that's for sure were you working for a
psychopathic son of a did you make
the wrong choice in University and was
that your father's fault because you
never did what you want or was it your
fault for not standing up to him or is
it a dying industry or is maybe this a
wake-up call that you should go do
something else that you've been waiting
to do you know that you've actually
wanted to do your whole life and that's
why you're doing such a miserable job at
your current occupation because you're
bitter and resentful about the fact that
you never did what you want you don't
know it's all of those things at once
and that's very stressful because all of
those things at once is too many things
and that's the re-emergence of chaos
that's the flood
that's the return to the beginning of
the cosmos that's another way that it's
been represented mythologically it's
that you Voyage all the way back to the
beginning of the cosmos when there's
nothing but undifferentiated chaos and
that's what you're confronting and maybe
it's too much for you and often it is I
mean that that can really that can be
traumatizing it can hurt your brain you
know it's just too much for you to Bear
but it doesn't matter you're stuck with
it and so how do you respond to that
well some of it is catastrophic negative
emotion you freeze and that's protective
and maybe you don't even want to move
you don't want to bloody well get out of
bed for a week and that's because your
body is reacting as if the bedroom floor
is covered with snakes and the best
thing for you to do is just not move
just freeze not a pleasant situation to
be in because it's your hyper aroused
very very physiologically demanding and
there's zero about it that's productive
except maybe the snakes won't see you
but they've already seen you so that
isn't helping very well so you've got
all this undifferentiated negative
emotion anxiety fear hurt anger guilt
shame emotional pain the whole plethora
of catastrophes and then maybe on the
other side lurking down there is thank
God I'm done with that job I just bloody
well hate it I drag myself off to work
every day and there's a little part of
my soul that's so goddamn happy I
finally got fired that I can hardly
stand it you know and maybe you don't
even admit that to yourself because well
that would mean that all that time you
spent at the job was just some cost
you're diluting yourself the whole time
um it is an interesting thing to
consider though sometimes if you're in
the unpleasant circumstance of having to
fire someone you know sometimes firing
someone is the best thing that can
happen to them which doesn't mean that
you should go out and like enjoy it
although I have met very disagreeable
people who actually enjoyed firing
people I'll tell you a story about that
at some point because it's quite
interesting but you know sometimes if
someone's just limping along in their
job and doing it as miserably and
wretchedly as they possibly can imagine
the best thing you can do to them for
them is to say you know
you're failing at this and and that
doesn't necessarily mean that you would
have to be failing at absolutely
everything else in the entire world so
maybe you should just accept the damn
failure and go off and try something new
and I mean that's terrifying for people
and I know they hate it and all that but
but
sometimes it's better than the
alternative which is just slow torturous
death
so
here's a funny way of looking at it
so let's say you fall right into that
hole that's underneath any everything
and you've hit an anomaly that you don't
understand you say what's that anomaly
made out of exactly I know that's a
strange way of thinking about it you
know because it's not
well you could say
we'll just go along with that it's a
metaphor what's that anomaly made out of
well here's a way of thinking about it's
made out of Spirited matter
and here's why
this is something I learned in part from
Piaget he said
well it's made out of matter because of
course that's the world matter and the
world is also what matters and so that's
kind of a nice Duality there but it's
made out of spirit because when you
encounter something anomalous and go
down the rabbit hole when you go into
the underworld it's underneath
everything that you've relied on
you learn things down there so what's
down there is information
and that now it's maybe way more
information than you want but it is
information it's information and what
can what can you do with the information
you can inform yourself with the
information right you can put yourself
in formation with the information that's
helpful too
and so and you think well you you're a
psyche maybe you're not a spirit it
depends on you know whether you're a
materialist or not but at least we can
say that you're a psyche the question is
what's your psyche made of well it's
obviously got a material substrate but
the matter happens to be a raid in a
particular order and that's an
information order and so when you fall
into the underworld that's underneath
everything and you encounter that latent
information then what you can do is
enhance your psyche you can grow your
spirit because what you do is you take
the new information and you incorporate
it that's like eating the Apple that
Adam and Eve ate you incorporate that
and that makes more of you and that's
not a metaphorical or a metaphysical
proposition it's not it's to say nothing
other than well that's what happens when
children learn you say think of what
happens Charles 3 has a pretty low
resolution representation of the world
and is a fairly low resolution human
being got all the constituent elements
there but isn't differentiated in any
tremendous manner that's all still to
come in the future and so what does the
child do explore what do they explore
things they don't understand that's
where the information is because you
already understand what you understand
there's no information there you go
where they're where you don't understand
that's where the information is and out
of that information you generate a
higher resolution world and you generate
a higher resolution self and so out of
the combat with the underlying Dragon of
chaos you generate spirit and matter and
that's what you do when you go down into
the underworld
so if it doesn't kill you
or if it doesn't make you wish you were
dead which it probably will but there's
a bunch of you that has to die down
there anyway so maybe that's not such a
bad thing because if you had this
relationship that ended in betrayal then
there's something that's just not
exactly right right there's something
that went and the reason I'm saying that
you think well that's kind of moralistic
it's like actually I don't mind being
moralistic in case you haven't noticed
but
but that's not it's not a fair comment
because you're playing this stupid game
it's like you live with someone
infidelity that's the game right you've
decided the rules with the game comes a
morality the morality are the rules of
the game well then the thing collapses
into infidelity it's like well you
played the game wrong or it was the
wrong game one of those two you it's one
of those two you pick the damn game and
having picked the game you can't all of
a sudden say well no those aren't the
rules it's like yeah yeah if you pick
the game you pick the rules and if you
fail at complying with the rules then
you failed now you could say well I
could pick a different game it's like I
don't care how you solve the problem
you're still stuck with the problem it's
a moral problem fundamentally
and it might take some major league
retooling too
to fix it
so you're at Point a trying to get to
point B that's not working out you hit
an anomaly
you're not getting to point B that's for
sure
your medical school student you write
your mcats which is this test you have
to write to go to medical school you get
25th percentile I don't know who you are
but you're not a pre-med student and
maybe you never were right and that's
the rub man and so who the hell are you
you don't know collapse down here into
this motivational conflict this place of
motivational and emotional uncertainty
and tremendous information right it's a
place of transformation it's the Phoenix
that burns it's the burning part of the
Phoenix that burns it's it's the journey
to the underworld it's the journey to
hell it can really be a journey to hell
because you may find out that the reason
that your partner betrayed you or that
you didn't get your damn promotions
because there is seriously something
wrong with you and you know it and I
don't just mean that you don't know what
you're doing I mean that there's 25
percent of you that is seriously aiming
at things not being good and so you fall
into the underworld and you find out
that oh
God I just got exactly what I was aiming
for or I got exactly what the worst part
of me was aiming for and that worst part
that's something to clean up and that's
not going to be easy because it's got
its hooks in me like something something
ferocious something seriously ferocious
and I've been toying with it for a very
long time and maybe I can't even detach
it anymore and so that's not so fun and
you see people like that in
Psychotherapy very frequently or you see
them wandering around on the streets
like the absolute catastrophic former
shells of themselves you know because
they've hit the underworld and they
ended up in hell and there's no getting
out of it and so those are the people
you tend to give a wide birth to when
you walk down the street also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
are you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five seek competence
it's a mistake to be fatally cynical
about politics because
for all the reasons there are to be
fatally cynical about politics there's
much more reason to be fatally cynical
about the conflict that will inevitably
arise or the Tyranny that will
inevitably manifest itself if we can't
handle the dirty business of politics
properly
so I would say don't become prematurely
cynical about it the next thing I would
say is
what do you know
and that's a very important question
it's like
what does it mean to get into politics
exactly does that mean to seek political
power does that mean to seek power
well first of all you shouldn't be
seeking power you should be seeking
competence
and in order to seek competence you
better know something and so I would say
well if you want to get into politics
you want to educate yourself you know in
all the things you need to be educated
in life I mean you can you can start to
play the political game to familiarize
yourself with it but you know it's not
such a bad idea to well it's not such a
bad idea to have a job for a while and
and maybe a career and maybe it's not
such a bad idea to have a successful
career upon in which people are
dependent on you so that you start to
understand what that sort of
responsibility means and then maybe it's
not such a bad idea to have a family
because like human beings mature adult
human beings tend to have families and
and they transform when they have
families because when you have children
then someone becomes more important to
you than you are and you're not mature
until that happens and so that's
necessary and so I would say well make
sure that if you're looking to get into
politics that you're even more looking
to get into competence and that you
learn everything you can possibly learn
that would make you a reasonably wise
person by the time you attain whatever
level of power you might Authority let's
say you might be seeking I mean I've
seen lots of people get into politics
you know this happens with ideologues
and the way they ratchet themselves up
the power hierarchy is by being more
effective avatars puppets of their
particular ideological stance and
there's nothing about that that's useful
there's nothing in it that will solve
any real world problems and there's
plenty that will make it much worse and
so if that's what getting into politics
means I would say stay the hell away
from it but if it's a matter of
developing your character and then at
some point adopting your social
responsibility then go for it and more
power to you because we need people who
are competent and careful and truthful
and courageous and forthright to enter
the political sphere so that things
don't degenerate and hopefully have some
ounce of at least maintaining themselves
or improving
so
there's you need what do you need to
know you you need to be really good at
at least one thing you have to
specialize you have to be a great
networker you have to know a lot of
people you have to be honest you have to
be articulate you have to you have to
have a vision you have to have a
strategy you have to know something
about history and economics and politics
be good to know something about science
you know you have to be a polymath of
sorts before you should dare to enter
that realm with any degree of confidence
because otherwise all you are is a Loose
Cannon and you'll come up with global
proposals to improve improve the world
you know by waving your wand that will
do nothing but make everything worse
rule number six determine your free will
I want to tell you a little bit about
how to conceptualize Free Will I think
first because it's obvious that we don't
have infinite free will our our choice
our choices are constrained in all sorts
of ways and I think part of the reason
that there's a
a continual discussion about Free Will
and the philosophical
in the philosophical literatures because
just conceptualizing the issue properly
is extraordinarily difficult so I like
to think about it at least in part the
way that you think about a game you know
if you're playing a game obviously the
game has rules so if it's a chess game
or a basketball game then there are
things that you can do in and things
that you can't do
and but and so it's it's a it's a it's a
closed World in some sense but the fact
that there are things you can't do when
you play a game also seem to open up a
universe of possibilities for things
that you can do so chess obviously
constrains you to a board and to a
certain number of men and to a certain
pattern of rules but the strange thing
is is that when you put in those rules
because rules sound like limits they
sound always like things you can't do
but when you set up a constrained world
like that and you lay out a system of
rules what you do is open up an Infinity
of of a near Infinity of possibilities
same with music You Know music has rules
obviously and and if you follow the
rules then you can make an infinite
variety of music and so
and so there's a there's a very
interesting Dynamic that's hard to
understand between constraint and
possibility and there's a deep idea
that's associated with that that I read
in some Jewish commentary on on the
biblical stories that I I read a long
time ago
um talking about the relationship
between God and man and the idea was
that God
imagine it being with the classical
attributes of God omniscience
omnipotence and omnipresence all seeing
all-knowing and all-powerful what is it
being like that lack
and obviously the answer is nothing
right because by definition those three
traits
provide for absence of limitation but
then that's exactly what's lacking is
limitation and there's some strange
connection between limitation and and I
was saying say limitation
that that's rule governed as I mentioned
before and the opening up of possibility
so
that isn't necessarily the case that now
determine determinism and limitation
aren't exactly the same thing but
they're analogous and they need to be
discussed together okay so now so that's
the first thing is that our whatever our
free choice is it isn't Limited it's or
it's limited it's it's deeply limited
now here's another thing if I take my
arm and I go like this
you see I'll do that again
now you see there's a movement like that
and then my hands stopped just before my
my other hand now it takes a certain
amount of time for the neural messages
to go from my brain to my arm and back
and the time it takes my hand to go like
this and stop is actually shorter than
the time it takes a message to get to my
brain and back so what that means is
that when I
when I plan this movement which is
called a ballistic movement it's called
a ballistic movement because it's like a
bullet once you let it go it's gone
there's no calling it back I've actually
organized the neurological and muscular
sequences that enable that action before
it's implemented I set all that up and
then it's released and the whole thing
Cascades and so
once the action has been released let's
say then I don't really have any free
will because I can't stop it now so so
you think about that it looks like
there's a temporal gradient with regards
to Free Will is that as you look out
into the future meet perhaps the farther
out you look into the future
um the farther down the road let's say
the more free your choices are but the
closer they get to implementation the
more they become deterministic governed
by standard causal processes and there's
some transition point where they change
from being what we would describe as
choice that we haven't got to free
choice yet but at least to choice
there's some transition point between
that and Ballistic movement rule number
seven pursue your goals we know enough
about psychology now to know that almost
all of the positive emotion that you're
going to experience in your life and
positive emotion is analgesic by the way
right it actually quells pain so it's
not just positive it also gets rid of
negative which is a big plus almost all
the positive emotion that you're going
to feel you're going to feel in
relationship to a goal because you feel
positive emotion as you approach a goal
and so if you want to feel positive
emotion then you need a goal and then
you might think well if you want to
maximize that positive emotion which is
enthusiasm and also what pulls you out
into the world as well as feeling good
then you need the best possible goal
well that because that's going to engage
them largest
segments of your being like if your goal
is too narrow then a bunch of you isn't
going to be on board for it you know if
the goal is well developed and
multi-faceted then all of you can
partake in that even your negative
elements even your anger and and your
fear can get on board with that let's
say so you need a goal man that's worthy
you got to think you're good you need a
goal that justifies the tragedy and
malevolence of life that seems to be the
bottom line now maybe you think well
there's no gold that can do that it's
like well
there are still better and worse goals
so and I'm not convinced that there are
no goals that can do that I think that's
an open question
you'd never know that until you pursued
the proper goal long enough to find out
who you would be
as a consequence of pursuing it so
that's also your destiny or your
existential Voyage right it's also not
something that anyone else can do for
you someone can say get your act
together for Christ's sake and get it
get get at it that's that'll make the
world unfold best for you but there's no
way you can know that without doing it
so
and unless you think you've done a
particularly Stellar job of that then
you have no reason to doubt its
potential validity
so plus like crickets are telling you
this and so
you know they're a very reliable source
okay so you see the star the star recurs
as a motif in Pinocchio and one of the
more interesting elements of it here is
that when Geppetto wants to transform
his puppet the marionette who's being
played by forces that operate behind the
scenes which is a really good definition
of the Persona from a union perspective
right and also something indicative of
something like an ideological or
conceptual possession
Geppetto who's a good guy he's a
positive father figure
lifts his even though he's a patriarchal
figure right and a very competent one he
still even lifts his eyes up to
something that transcends his motive
being positive as it is and wishes that
his creation would undertake the kind of
transformation that would make it
autonomous and fully functional as a
moral agent no strings right so that's
very interesting I think
said the salvation of mankind lies only
in making everything the concern of all
that's a pretty decent star-like goal I
would say
and so what happens in the Pinocchio
story is that because and I think this
is a symbolic representative of what I
just described to you that happens at a
genetic level if you put yourself in new
situations so
Geppetto is roughly culture in the
Pinocchio story right he's he's a
Craftsman he's he's a and and he makes
Pinocchio so he's he's
who's his son he's the socializing agent
and
he aims for something above mere
socialization which is I think part of
the mysterious element of human beings
you know in our scientific models we
basically have socialization and biology
but there's always a third element
mythological stories which is whatever
you might construe as the spontaneous
action of Consciousness that's
associated with free will and you know
that's just basically being
conceptualized in religious terms as
something akin to the soul now we don't
have a category for that scientifically
because what we try to do scientifically
is to reduce everything either to
socialization or to biology
but it isn't clear to me that that's
it's perfectly reasonable from the
perspective of practicality at a
scientific level you don't want to
multiply explanatory principles Beyond
necessity but there's many things that
that doesn't come to terms with such as
the fact that we all treat each other as
autonomous beings with Free Will and
that that seems to work and that if we
stop doing that then things go to hell
very very rapidly so and the mere fact
that we have been able to conceptualize
what that conscious Free Will might be
metaphysically or physically doesn't
mean it doesn't exist it just means that
we don't understand it I mean what it
was only in the last 15 years that we
discovered that 95 of the universe was
made out of some kind of matter that we
can't even
whose properties we can't even imagine
except that it seems to have mass
so
anyways what happens is when Geppetto
reach lifts his eyes up to the star
he so it's Society aligning itself with
the proper goal with regards to
individual development right so so there
instead of society being at odds with
the individual they line up and then
what happens is nature comes on board
that's the Blue Fairy in the in the
Pinocchio story and that's seems to me
to be a symbolic representation of what
happens biologically when when you set
the goal properly get your culture
behind you and move into the world is
that
there's a biological transformation that
occurs as a consequence of that which
means that a bunch of you that hasn't
been turned on turns on
and I guess one question would be is
what would you be like if you turned on
everything inside of you that could be
turned on
well that's a good goal that's a good
thing to find out
so
now
I'm going to introduce a couple of other
ideas so
there's this idea in jungian Psychology
called the circumambulation and Jung had
this idea that you had a potential
future self which would be in potential
everything that you could be and that it
manifests itself moment to moment in
your present Life by making you
interested in things and the things that
you're interested in are the things that
would guide you along the path that
would lead you to maximal development
now it sounds like a metaphysical idea
or a or a mystical idea even but but
it's not it's it's not it's a really
profoundly biological idea the idea is
something like well
you're set up so that you're
automatically interested in those things
that with fully expand you as a
well-adapted creature well like there's
nothing radical about that idea how well
what else could possibly be the case
unless there's something fundamentally
flawed about you that is what the
situation would be it's kind of
interesting to think about how that
would be manifest moment to moment but
the idea is something like well your
interest is captured by those things
that lead you down the path of
development
well that better be the case Okay so
that's fine and so there's some utility
in pursuing those things that you're
interested in that's the Call to
Adventure let's say
so and the call to adventure takes you
all sorts of places now the problem with
the Call to Adventure is like what the
hell do you know
you might be interested in things that
are kind of warped and bent
and often it's the case that when new
parts of people manifest themselves and
grip their interests say they do it very
badly and shortly
and so you stumble around like an idiot
when you try to do something new that's
why the fool is the precursor to the
Savior from the from the symbolic
perspectives because you have to be a
fool before you can be a master and if
you're not willing to be a fool then you
can't be a master so
so you're gonna it's an error error
written process and that's also laid out
in the Old Testament stories because the
first thing that happens to all these
patriarchal figures when God kicks them
out of their father's house when they're
like 84 is that they they run into all
sorts of trouble and some of it's social
and some of it's natural and some of
it's a consequence of their own moral
inadequacy so they're fools and but but
the thing that's so interesting is that
despite the fact that they're fools
they're still supposed to go on the
adventure and that they're capable of
learning enough as a consequence of
moving forward on the adventure so that
they straighten themselves out across
time
and so it's something like this this
circumambulation that Jung talked about
was this continual we'll return to this
this continual circling in some sense of
who you could be you might notice for
example that there are themes in your
life you know when you go back across
your experiences you see you kind of
have your typical experience that sort
of repeats itself and there might be
variation on it like a musical theme but
it's it's like you're circling yourself
and getting closer to yourself as you
move across time that's the
circumambulation now you remember that
for a sec because we'll go back to it
okay so imagine that something glimmers
before you it's an interest that's
Dawning and you decide well first of all
you're paralyzed you think well how do I
know if I should pursue that it's
probably a stupid idea and the proper
response to that is you're right it
probably is a stupid idea because almost
all all ideas are stupid and so the the
probability that as you move forward on
your adventure that you're going to get
it right the first time is zero you just
not going to happen and so then you
might think well maybe I'll just wait
around until I get the right idea and
which people do right so they're like 40
year old 13 year olds which is not a
good idea so they wait around until it's
waiting for Godot until they finally got
it right but the problem is you're too
stupid to know when you've got it right
so waiting around isn't going to help
because even if it the perfect
opportunity manifested itself to you in
your incomplete form the probability
that you would recognize it as the
perfect opportunity is zero you might
even think it's the worst possible idea
that you've ever heard of anywhere
highly likely highly likely so so you
have there's Nitric called that a will
to stupidity which I really liked so
because he thought of stupidity as being
it you know it's it's you have to take
it into account fundamentally and work
with it and so and so you can take these
tentative steps on your pathway to
Destiny and you can assume that you're
going to do it badly and that's really
useful because you don't have to beat
yourself up it's pretty easy to do it
badly
but the thing is it's way better to do
it badly than not to do it at all and
that's the continual message that Echoes
through these historical stories in
Genesis it's like these are flawed
people they they should have got the
hell out of their house way before they
did
um and they go out and they stumble
around in tyranny and famine and
self-betrayal and and
violence and but it's a hell of a lot
better than just rotting away at home
rule number eight don't be too harsh on
yourself it's not all that happens
though when they eat the fruit of the
tree of the knowledge of Good and Evil
because it's not called the fruit of the
tree of the knowledge of nakedness it's
called the fruit of the tree of the
knowledge of Good and Evil and I thought
about that for a tremendous amount of
time it's like what in the world because
I assume these old stories make sense
you know it's a game I play it's like
they're old they've been around a long
time I'm not sure why they're there but
there they are they're at the basis of
our culture like many many of the
stories that we depend on depend on them
our whole culture grew out of their
Roots let's say and so I assume that our
ancestors who managed to survive
conditions that would have done a lot of
us in very rapidly I can tell you were a
lot smarter than we think and that the
mysterious processes that that produce
these stories and compelled us to
remember them are a lot more
psychologically significant than we
generally tend to presume so I give them
the benefit of the doubt and try to
understand why it is that they might
make sense instead of assuming that they
don't and that that's not easy
because they're complicated stories and
so I thought about this nakedness
knowledge of Good and Evil idea for a
very very long time like about 20 years
puzzling it out was what the hell is the
relationship between discovering that
you're naked and discovering good and
evil and then one day mostly because of
studying totalitarianism
totalitarianism and the atrocity the
proclivity for people to commit atrocity
in the service of their group belief or
maybe just because that's what they were
like
clued me in
and I thought I see this is one of the
things that really makes people
different than animals it's like you
know it's one thing to realize that
you're naked to realize that you're
naked means that you know that you're
limited in time and space that you're
mortal and that you're you're subject to
degeneration and to social humiliation
and to your own harsh judgment all of
that nakedness to Know That You're
vulnerable against the world and
definitely a source of shame because of
that
um and and a felt lack of
self-sufficiency and no wonder and no
wonder it's understandable but the other
thing is is that this is and this is the
rub it's like
if you're out in a veld and you're not
being very careful and a hungry lion
jumps on you and eats you you don't
really think of the lion as evil I mean
you might write at that moment but you
know philosophically it's not evil it's
just hungry and as soon as it's not
hungry then
goes and has a sleep and it's not up to
some malevolent trick it's it's done for
the day but human being that's a whole
different sort of creature and because
human being is capable of doing terrible
things to someone else and consciously
so think well what's the connection
between that and nakedness itself and it
seems to be this is like here's the
thing is that once I realized that I can
be hurt you know I have a self-conscious
model of my own vulnerability
then I can generalize that to other
people I can think oh this is
interesting here's how I can be heard by
myself here's how I can be hurt by
Society here's how I can be hurt by
nature and by the unknown and what that
implies is that well you can be hurt
with exactly the same mechanisms
and that immediately becomes part of my
what would you say my repertoire of
ability
and then all of a sudden you the world
is no longer
a walled
a Walled Garden and a well-watered place
but it's a moral story because with that
ability to inflict suffering comes the
knowledge of good and evil as far as I'm
concerned those are identical
propositions because now we have the
choice a deep choice about how we're
going to treat ourselves and each other
we can inflict tremendous pain and
suffering on each other in a very
voluntary and and conscious manner in in
a way that no other animal can manage
and that's the dawning of the moral
sense that capacity we now have to
choose to
mitigate or exaggerate suffering and and
that's not all but it's a huge part of
it rule number nine work on your
attractiveness physical attractiveness
is a very complex trait
um it's also for example it's a marker
of health and of course health is a mar
is a prerequisite for Success so
um I you can't take attractiveness as a
unitary Dimension and measure it
sufficiently accurately
wait I should back up on that
no one that I know of has taken physical
attractiveness as a unitary concept
measured it accurately and then pitted
against IQ and the big five to see if it
to what degree it adds incremental
validity to the prediction of long-term
success
but physical but and so I can't give you
a technical answer you know I can say
well in a complex job over the long run
IQ accounts for maybe 20 percent of the
variance in success leaving 80 percent
therefore random events and and the big
five traits and connection networks and
and family background and all those
other things gender perhaps that all the
other things that determine success
physical we know that physical that
people who are physically attractive
though are given the benefit of Doubt by
other people they they benefit from the
positive halo effect and the positive
halo effect is the propensity of people
to assume good things about someone if
there is one outstanding thing about
them that's easily evident that's good
and so if you're if you're if you stand
up straight with your shoulders back so
that's rule 1 and 12 rules for life then
people are going to see you as more
attractive if you're symmetrical you're
more attractive if you're thin but not
too thin you're more attractive
um
well and then there's like good skin and
good teeth and good hair and and all of
those things in proper proportions and
youth and there's a whole slew of things
that that that feed into that if you are
characterized by a plethora of those
features then people are also going to
assume that you're more competent and
more
um and more
more worth having around let's say but
the problem is is that you are
so separating out the attractiveness
from the things the attractiveness are
is correlated with is very hard that's
why you have to do multivariate analysis
that's multi-variable analysis in any
complex social science because a lot of
these traits overlap
so but you know you can you can there's
there's some some things you can do
about that postural adjustment is
helpful to work out with weights that's
extraordinarily helpful that that
increases improves your posture and
makes you more confident and and and and
and and and
you can dress reasonably well and
intelligently and
um all of those things to to help
yourself capitalize on whatever
attractiveness you can muster I don't
know number 10 the last one before some
very special bonus Clips stay sane you
need structure you need predictability
and you need more of it than you think
just to keep you sane now if you're
lucky and and maybe a bit odd you can
deviate five percent from the norm or
ten percent from the norm or something
like that carefully and cautiously as
long as the rest of you is all well
ordered in a normative manner you might
be able to get away with that and you
might be able to sustain it across time
and people might be able to tolerate you
if you do it or maybe you'll get really
lucky and you happen to be creative but
reasonably well put together and people
will actually be happy that there's
something idiosyncratic and unique about
you but even under those circumstances
mostly what you want is to
have a routine that's disciplined it's
predictable and bloody well stick to it
you're going to be way healthier and
happier and saner if you do that and
then the other thing that you need
because this is one of the things the
psychoanalysts got wrong I think is that
they overestimated the degree to which
sanity was a consequence of internal of
being properly structured internally you
know
because from the psychoanalytic point of
view you're sort of an ego and that ego
is inside you and of course it rests on
an unconscious structure but the purpose
of psycho and Analysis is to sort out
that unconscious structure and the ego
on top of it and to make you uh fully
functioning and autonomous individual
but there's a problem with that because
the reason that you're saying as a fully
functional and autonomous human being
isn't because you've organized your
psyche even though that's important the
reason that you're saying if you're
aware if you have a well-organized
unconscious and ego is because other
people can tolerate having you around
for reasonably extensive periods of time
and will cuff you across the back of the
head every time you do something so
stupid that people will dislike you
permanently if you continue and so what
people are doing to each other all the
time just non-stop is broadcasting
sanity signals back and forth right it's
like you smile at people if they're well
if they're not not only behaving
properly but behaving in a way that you
would like to see them continue to
behave you frown at them if they're not
you ignore them if they're not you shun
them you you roll your eyes at them you
manifest a disgust face you don't listen
to them you interrupt them you won't
cooperate with them you won't compete
with them it's like you're blasting
signals of other people about how to
regulate their behavior
so frequently well it just makes up all
of your social interaction that's why we
face each other and we have emotional
displays on our face and we're looking
at each other's eyes and we know exactly
we know as much as we can about what's
going on with each other given that we
don't have immediate access to the
contents of their Consciousness and so
partly what you're doing with your
routine is establishing yourself as a
credible reliable trustworthy
potentially interesting human being who
isn't going to do anything too erratic
at any moment and everyone else is
around there tapping you into shape
making sure that that's exactly what you
are and that's how you stay sane and so
what happens to people too if they don't
have a routine and they get isolated as
they start to drift and they drift badly
because the world is too complicated for
you to keep it organized all by yourself
you just cannot do it so a lot of our so
we Outsource the problem of sanity
and it's very intelligent that we
Outsource the problem of Sanity because
sanity is an impossibly complex problem
and so the way that we manage the
incredibly complex problem is we have a
very large number of brains working
simultaneously on the problem all the
time it's like a stock market for sanity
and it's partly and I use that I use
that definition with purpose because the
stock market does the same kind of
impossible thing right because it tries
to price things which is impossible
there's how many things are there like a
billion how in the world do you decide
what the price is you can't decide what
the price is that's why you have a stock
market I said well in a free market I
mean for for consumer goods is
everyone's voting on what the price of
everything is all the time and that's
the way we figured out because it's
actually it's technically impossible
that's partly why the stock market
explodes now and then and there's
Bubbles and all that sort of thing but
anyways the point is
things are chaotic in Alice in
Wonderland when Ellis goes down the
rabbit hole
that's the underworld right
so now she's gone into the substructure
of being
and she meets the red queen and the Red
Queen is Mother Nature
and mother nature is running around
yelling off with their heads off with
her heads
which is of course what Mother Nature
does and she tells Ellis in My Kingdom
you have to run as fast as you can just
to stay in the same place
and that's exactly right and that's a
description of
in fact evolutionary biologists
psychologists have picked up on that
phrase they call it the Red Queen
problem and the Red Queen problem is
everything's after you all the time and
you're not smart enough to do anything
about it or enough about it
and so that's a permanent existential
problem so how do you deal with that
you've got a biological structure
so your embodiment is part of the
solution to the problem and then you're
enculturated
and because you're enculturated
so you're taught a lot of things that
you need to know but mostly what you're
taught is how to communicate with other
people in an acceptable manner and then
once you can communicate with people in
an acceptable manner then you can
Outsource your problems constantly but
you're doing constantly and so we're in
this continual Dynamic exchange of
problem solving so if you're a
socialized person that's what you get
access to and that's something to know
if you're going to have kids and I
mentioned this I think in a previous
lecture
per the purpose of being a parent for
very young children is to make your
children
exceptionally socially desirable by the
age of four because if you can do that
they're set because everyone wants them
around and as soon as everybody wants
them around they want to play with them
they want to cooperate when they want to
compete with them it's like the door is
open the door is open and they stay sane
because they've got all sorts of people
who actually like them that are helping
them out and so that's your goal is to
make them as socially acceptable as you
possibly can socially desirable as you
possibly can and that doesn't mean
you render them obedient without Spirit
right that's that's a tyrants mode of of
enforcing social acceptability it's like
never do anything wrong well that's not
any way to I mean that's a good piece of
advice you know like but
it's missing the other half which is do
a bunch of things that are right so that
so that people are thrilled to have you
around and to and encourage that that's
what you want to do as a parent as well
as inculcating the order and so you know
and in this little diagram I indicated
that there's God the Father with the son
behind him and he's ruling over this
walled City so he's like The Meta Spirit
of the walled City
it's very very nice very nice image
brilliant image so it's is the
collective Spirit of the city that's
another way of thinking about it or the
collective Spirit of the city across
time or the collective Spirit of the
force that built and maintained the city
across time even better and that's
associated with the sun because it's a
it's it's it's associated with
Enlightenment and illumination and all
of those things that we associate with
higher Consciousness and vision it's a
brilliant image and then I overlaid this
you know now of course the the
patriarchal
aspect of existence can become
tyrannical
it does that quite regularly it's one of
the existential dangers of human
civilization is that Civilization is a
medication for chaos but it can spin out
of control in and of itself and become
its own sort of problem which is like a
hyper order problem generally which then
produces a chaos problem so every
solution carries within it certain
problems right because no solution is
perfect and so you have to keep things
in Balance but it's one of the reasons
that I'm really uh
let's call it irritated about the
postmodernists because they keep
yammering about the patriarchy and it's
very very annoying because because it's
self-evident that social structures are
tyrannical it's like that's not news
folks that's obvious but that's not all
they are and it's it's the it's the
reduction of the entire
complex
solution let's say to a uni-dimensional
problem it's just tyranny it's like no
actually it's not just tyranny if you
spent six months somewhere that was just
tyranny you'd know the difference very
very rapidly and that doesn't mean that
everyone doesn't give up a pound or two
or ten or Twenty of Flesh to participate
even in a society that's as free as a
western Society is we all get crushed
and molded by the tyrannical force of
social convention
but at least in principle the benefit is
worth the cost and then it's also up to
you to make sure that you don't
sacrifice more to the group than you
should and you can start to tell if
you're sacrificing more to the group
than you should because you start to
become resentful of other people that's
part of that that's part of the
psychological mechanism that's informing
you of that so it's up to you to fight
against the you know the overarching
pressure for Conformity to retain your
individual logos let's say but that's
sort of your problem it's like the group
wants you to behave
now if you could behave and be
creatively productive so much the better
but that's pretty damn rare so the group
generally tends to settle just for
behave and there's a tyrannical element
of that but what the hell is the
alternative it's you know our society is
based on consensus and the consensus is
based on the sacrifice of a certain
sacrifice of individuality even though
individuality is absolutely necessary as
a revitalizing force for this Society
it's a very tight touch tough thing to
manage properly
part of the cultural battle that we all
find ourselves enveloped in is partially
due to the claim that there's virtually
nothing other than the lust for power
and you know I would say
fair enough in some limited sense which
and that's
that bears directly on your question
because you see that as a Temptation
that might be powerful enough to bend
and distort you as you attempt to make
your way through let's say the halls of
power
well
[Music]
I heard recently from a reliable source
that Putin's conversion to Orthodox
Christianity might be genuine
and then you might think well if you're
atheistic
well that's not necessarily a good thing
or maybe you think it's a bad thing or
maybe you think it's
an irrelevant issue and you may also
think it's a lie but
I would say that
I would be more inclined to trust
someone who thinks there's something
higher than himself
and then you might say well what is it
that's higher than ourselves and that's
we're thinking about and we all need to
think about this regardless of the
particulars of our religious belief and
I would say
again from a clinical perspective
service to others is really something
people who are depressed tend to use the
pronouns I and me much more frequently
than people who aren't depressed and I'm
not saying that people get depressed
because they're selfish I'm not saying
that at all I'm saying that one of the
way out one of the roots out of
depression appears to be an increase in
service to other people and I think the
reason for that is because we aren't
power mad demons at the core even though
we may be tempted by such things and
that we find the genuine meaning that
offsets genuine suffering in the genuine
service to others and I think it's a big
mistake to be cynical especially
prematurely about such things as
political activity because they're
necessary despite let's say they're
adversarial and uh and uh
party-centered nature partisan nature
you have to be clear about what you
serve and why
and that has to be held higher always
than mere Victory mere
operationalized Victory or instrumental
Victory it's a very very difficult thing
to to negotiate particularly because in
the political Realm
in some sense you have to defeat your
enemy right because you have to win the
election and the other people have to
lose it's a binary choice but so often I
see in partisan discussion the
proclivity to assume that all the ill
will and malevolence resides on the
other side of the chamber
and that's a big mistake and you could
think about that more deeply too is that
we all have to put we all need a place
to place the existence of malevolence
right because malevolence clearly exists
and we're all suffer from the weight of
malevolent history right because even
the grounds we walk on here which this
is a remarkable and wonderful place I
mean English soil is soaked with blood
just like the soil of every place in the
world that's part of the human Heritage
and all of us bear the marks of that
conflict in some sense in our souls
partly because of the possibility for us
to engage in that but also partly
because part of the reason we're here in
all this privilege is because of all
that catastrophe
well the best way to localize that
malevolence is inside you
right and to remember that the enemy
that you're fighting with the greatest
enemy that you ever fight with is in
your own heart and that'll also stop you
from confusing that true source of
malevolence let's say with your mere
political enemies and that isn't to say
that you won't encounter malevolent
Behavior although most of it in the
political sphere as it is everywhere
most of it is more ignorance than
malevolence although willful blindness
certainly plays a large role and so you
need to know what it is that you're
serving and I would say one of the ways
to do that practically are a couple of
ways to do that practically is you need
a good team around you the people you
really trust and who can watch you and
who do it with a certain degree of
impartiality and who are disagreeable
enough to talk to you when you do
something wrong so you need trusted
advisors and then the other thing I
would say is you really need to listen
to your constituents
because they will tell you what the
problems are if you listen to them and
if you really listen to them well then
you'll have your feet on the ground
which is where they should be and you'll
know what the problems are and you will
win elections
because what people really want from
their leaders is to be listened to and
then for those leaders to articulate
what they've heard in the halls of let's
say influence and Power and so if you
know those things if you know you need
to listen you need to get in touch with
the people you're representing as
regularly as you possibly can and mostly
to listen
um I knew a man in Canada who started a
political party which is a very
difficult thing to do and not only did
he start it but he wrote it to
sufficient success though that he became
the leader of the opposition in Canada
within about 10 years and I asked him
how he did that because it's like well
really how did you do that that's
actually really hard and he said he
would go out from constituency to
constituency and make his stump speeches
but what he really liked was the Q and
A's because people would tell him what
their problems were then he knew what
the problems were and out of the
dialogue would also emerge the answers
that the audience found compelling and
so not only would they tell them what
the problems were but they would tell
him the answers they would like to have
it have have what instituted to solve
those problems it's the same thing that
comedians do when they when they finast
finesse their acts in front of live
audiences before they practice them in
front of a large audience they lit they
tell jokes and the audience see their
laughs or they don't if they laugh then
you keep that joke and if they don't you
throw it out and soon you're just as
funny as the audience can possibly
manage and it's the same thing you can
also do that in a dark manner by the way
which is what Hitler did
so he could utter terrible things and
wait for response and collect those and
so then you become the embodiment of The
Shadow of Your people so I would
recommend that you probably don't do
that you go to a party your heart's
beating why the party is a monster why
because it's judging you and it's
judging you it's putting you low down
the dominance hierarchy because that's
what a negative judgment is and that
interferes with your sexual success and
that means that you're being harshly
evaluated by Nature itself right so you
are confronting that the dragon of chaos
when you go into the social situation
and so what do you do you're like this
right you hunch over and that's low
dominance I'm no threat it's like oh
that's not going to get you very far you
know but that's a logical thing to do in
in the in in the face of a tyrant so I'm
no threat you know you look at the king
and you're dead I'm no threat I'm
hunched over and then what's happening
internally how what are people thinking
about me what are people thinking about
me am I looking stupid am I looking
foolish geez I'm awkward I hate being
here man I'm sweating too much it's all
internalized right it's all self-focused
the the eye isn't worked the eye isn't
working what do you tell people
stop don't stop thinking about yourself
because you can't it's like don't think
of a white elephant white elephant white
elephant white elephant you can't tell
someone to stop thinking about something
because they get caught in the loop what
you do with socially anxious people is
you say look at other people look at
them right why because if you look at
them you can tell what they're thinking
and then you you unless you're unless
you're terribly socialized and some
people are some people have no social
skills and so the reason they can't go
to a party is because they don't even
know how to introduce themselves like
they're just no one ever taught them how
to behave and so they're really good
candidates for behavior therapy because
you walk them through the process of how
you actually
manifest the procedures that are
associated with social acceptability but
most people aren't like that they have
the ability so if they're really
introverted in higher neuroticism they
can usually talk quite well to someone
one-on-one why because they look at them
well if I look at you it's another thing
to do if you're ever speaking to a group
of people never speak to the group of
people that doesn't exist you talk to
individuals and then they reflect for
you the entire group because they're all
entrained so you look at one person they
broadcast you what everyone's thinking
and you know how to talk to one person
so it's easy so as soon as you focus on
the person not you you push your
attention outward use your eye you push
your attention outward and you start
watching well then all your automatic
mechanisms kick in and you start being
awkward because if we're talking and I'm
looking here
I don't know what you're going to do
next and I'm going to put disjunctions
into the like they're like uh bad cords
in The Melody of our of our conversation
and the reason is I'm not paying
attention so that's why the eye is the
thing at the top of the pyramid it's
like the thing that enables you to win
the set of all possible dominance
herkies is the I pay attention pay
attention that's the critical issue
that's why the Egyptians worshiped Horus
that's why Horus was the thing that
rescued Osiris from the from the depths
it's the capacity to pay attention what
do you pay attention to most
what your right hemisphere signals as
anomalous it attracts your attention
it's like this isn't going quite right
I'm not looking at that wrong
that's what you look at that's what you
look at what's not going right because
that's see that's the terrible monster
that might eat you but it's also the
place you get all the information
so that's why it's useful to have
discussions with your enemies
because they will tell you things you do
not know and that's such a great thing
because if you don't know them well
you're not very smart are you you know
there may be a time when you go
somewhere that's the thing you need to
know and maybe your enemy will tell you
why you're such a fool you know and a
bunch of other things that aren't true
too
but even one thing that's accurate it's
like yeah thanks very much man maybe
I'll do some work on that and I won't
have to carry that forward so and then
that's part of the reason again why the
terrible Predator it's always the
terrible Predator that has the gold it's
like it's the person who delivers the
message you do not want to hear
so it's rough it's rough but it doesn't
matter life is rough if you're looking
for certainty
the reality of suffering is certain
I mean
what do you accept as evidence Above All
Else
that's a good question that's a hard
question but I would say pain is up
there
it's very difficult not to believe in
the reality of your own pain
it's somewhat easier not to believe in
the reality of other people's pain
that's not so easy either you know but
it's your pain seems to be
undeniably real
and so
it does beg a question which is you know
if pain is undeniably real is that which
overcomes pain even more real
and I think that's in some sense that's
the idea that lurks behind the idea of
the Resurrection I don't know how many
of you have read dostoevsky's crime and
punishment but I would highly recommend
that in crime and punishment the
protagonist commits the perfect murder
and he has his reasons for it and many
reasons because Dostoevsky didn't mess
around when he wanted to give someone
reasons he gave them reasons and
raskolnikov that main character had
reasons for murder and then he commits
his murder and he gets away with it
but things don't go well for skolnikov
because one of the things he finds out
is that the riskalnikov that you were
before you committed the murder
is not the same as the riskolnikov as
you are after you've committed the
murder and there's a dividing line there
that you don't
it's like the red pill I guess right
it's like it that's the Matrix correct
the red pill
and once there's certain actions once
you take them there's no going back
and so that's what crime and punishment
is about and riskolnikov tortures
himself to death well not literally but
metaphysically psychologically because
he cannot tolerate
breaking the great moral code
and so that's what's a great book it's
truly a great book and and it's also
extraordinarily like it's a it's a it's
a it's a murder mystery thriller as as
well as being a deep philosophical book
so if you're in the mood for you know a
murder mystery thriller that's also a
deep philosophical book then that's the
one for you you speak about the concept
of the Soul
um do you associate this with any
psychological constructs
not any psychological constructs that
are more valid than the notion of the
Soul
you know there's there's I would say
what we mean by soul is something like
animating spirit
and you might say well what's a spirit
and well that's actually rather easy to
answer so when a child of four is
playing house
let's say what a child of four is
playing house she
acts out the role of the mother
but acting out that's a strange thing
right because she doesn't literally
duplicate in her actions or her
Perceptions in the game what she
observed her mother literally doing so
for example she didn't go into her
mother's bedroom when her mother awoke
and watched her turn her head in a
particular way to awaken and count the
number of blanks so that she could mimic
that in her play and you know you think
that's absurd but it's not absurd if
it's just mimicry it's not it's
unbelievably sophisticated so what the
girl does is she watches her mother
manifest maternal Behavior across a vast
array of instances and she integrates
that with the image of the mother she's
received from all the books she's been
read and all the little movies she's
watched the Disney movies and so forth
and she abstracts out the animating
principle of the maternal and then she
embodies that in play and usually with a
little boy and that's practice for
what's going to come later it's
unbelievably sophisticated and she's
embodying a spirit and the spirit there
is the abstraction of the central
animating principle from multiple
embodiments of its manifest station and
if you think children can't do that well
then you don't know anything about
children because they do that all the
time in their pretend play which is a
necessary precursor to healthy
psychological development and so part of
what we refer to as the soul is the
presence of that Spirit or maybe even
the capacity of embodying such spirits
and it's very difficult to know how deep
that goes
you know I had a vision at one point of
all the men in my life who've been
particularly influential in a benevolent
way
you know and so and you think well just
a mirror notion of the idea that there
could be a benevolent way that would
unite the acts of benevolence across a
series of men that's all comprehensible
to you that's you take that as a matter
of course when you say that there are
such things as good men and you can
identify them right something stable
about whatever is good across multiple
manifestations of of incarnation let's
say and I saw that transform into the
the father person of the Trinity as the
embodiment of that benevolent Spirit now
I don't have any idea what that means
metaphysically because who does but but
that
that Spirit manifesting itself within is
certainly part of what we refer to when
we talk about the soul and you can see
that shine through people I mean it's
part of what gives someone Charisma it's
part of what elicits the instinct to
imitate in you
you know when you see that even in
simple things when you see a remarkable
athlete do something incredibly athletic
to put the goal to put the soccer ball
the football ball through the net to
score the goal and everybody leaps to
their feet in celebration of that well
that's that's a celebration of the
Divine capacity to hit the target dead
on and it grips you at such a a low
level way down inside your soul that
you're compelled to your feet to cheer
and you don't even know what you're
doing
but you enjoy it that's for sure and
that enjoyment is also a sign of the
depth and utility of that response you
see this in all all the things that
people do that are you know so-called
popular entertainment it's unbelievably
sophisticated
the soul is participating in that in the
fullest extent and you know you can say
well there's no use for the religious
there's no necessary use for the
religious terminology it's like well
until you come up with a better word
there's plenty of use for it because
it's a very complex and deep phenomena
and to you know just
casted into the realm of superstition in
some casual manner is it's just not
helpful not in any possible it's not
helpful scientifically it's not helpful
ethically it's not helpful existentially
try treating someone for a while as if
they don't have a soul
just really I mean it just you know
treat them like a deterministic machine
if that's your belief
really act it out you'll be like the
most hated person in town in about 15
minutes well I mean what do you make of
practical evidence like that I mean you
interact with people as if they're free
Souls capable of choosing between good
and evil that's what you do all the time
and maybe you can Addle yourself out of
that by some ridiculous rationalist
ideology but that just means you're kind
of a gabbling fool and it's just going
to make you trip over things you don't
even notice in all of your social
interactions and you tell me I don't
care how you think philosophically or
ideologically you bloody well know that
what I just said is true
so and that's true even when you're
interacting with an infant or a small
child it's true when you're dealing with
someone who's elderly and virtually
incapacitated in every way you still see
that Divine spark for lack of a better
term and we do lack a better term by the
way you see that everywhere if your eyes
are open and if you're willing to see it
and to the degree that you're responsive
to that then
your actions are Guided by love and your
words are Guided by truth when you
organize your perceptions around a goal
that provides a container for your
negative emotions so if I want to walk
across the stage because I think that
getting to the other side is preferable
to being here so that's a hierarchy of
value that place is better than this
place
than when I observe myself undertaking
the actions that will get me to that
place that's comforting and provides
security because it shows that the
structure that I'm using to organize my
perceptions and to reduce the world to a
manageable
to manageability
is sufficiently accurate so that I can
implement it
and so we seem to inhabit those
structures all the time whenever we're
looking at the world whenever we're
interacting we specify a goal and so
that's an ethical Enterprise and we
organize our emotions within the
specification of that goal and then we
produce hierarchies of goals so you know
you go to you
you sit down in front of your computer
so you can write a paper and you write a
paper so that you can finish an essay
and you finish an essay so that you can
get a grade in a class and get a grade
to class so that you can graduate with a
degree and you do that so that you can
get a job and you do that so that you
can be what a good husband a good wife a
good citizen and you do that so you can
be a good person
there's a hierarchy of ethic that
permeates the entire Enterprise right
from the microcosm up to the macrocosm
and I think that's something like the
whole landscape of religious value with
the
outermost container so be a good person
let's say that's the
ultimate aim of the religious Enterprise
that's something like the imitation of
Christ in the most fundamental sense and
all the things that you do within that
are a reflection of that or you're
confused and chaotic and if everyone's
doing that at the same time then you
have a society that's integrated and
aiming up and capable of telling the
truth something like that does that seem
reasonable and so so what's the
proposition here well I think when we
describe these Frameworks of perception
the name we give to the description of a
framework of perception is a story
and I think the reason that we like
stories so much is because we need
to establish Frameworks of perception in
order to operate in the world and to
allow ourselves to
be integrated peacefully with other
people
and so we're extraordinarily interested
in anything that has a narrative basis
and the reason we're interested in that
is because we're trying to build within
ourselves and collectively the structure
that enables us to perceive the world
without undue confusion and chaos and in
a manner that provides some value to us
and some sustainability that's the goal
overall
and
that seems to me to be the goal of the
entire religious Enterprise and so
is it possible that
well I guess that's his that's the claim
I thought I'd
elaborate out a little bit today is that
the Bible is true
in a very strange way
it's true in that
it provides the basis for
truth itself
and so it's like a meta truth right
without it there without it there
couldn't even be the possibility of
Truth
and so maybe that's the most true thing
the most true thing isn't some truth per
se it's that which provides the
precondition for all judgments of Truth
and it seems to me that
I can't see any holes in that argument
and I can't see any holes in it from a
scientific perspective either because I
think we do know well enough now as
scientists that the problem of deriving
ethical direction from the collection of
facts is an intractable problem there's
too many facts there's an infinite
number of facts they do not provide an
unerring guide for Action they can't
there's too many of them they have to be
prioritized
and as soon as they are prioritized well
then you're in the ethical domain and
then that begs the question what's the
valid ethical domain and the postmodern
answer is well there isn't one it's all
the expression of domination and power
and I think that's nonsense I I don't
think that's a tenable solution I think
that
we stumbled onto the proper answer in
some sense in our religious Enterprise
which is that we aim at what's highest
or or we don't
we aim at what's highest jointly or
we're divided we aim at what's highest
and that's gives meaning to all the
things we do that are subordinate parts
of that we aim at what's highest and
that's what collects us and gives us
structure all of that you know singly
and jointly
and that's all what we've been trying to
communicate
all these centuries as we've been trying
to communicate the whole religious
Corpus generation after generation and
to sort this out and to straighten it
out and to try to understand it
and uh
I think that's where we're at now you
know pick something aim at it as you
move toward it you'll get wiser then
maybe your aim will change that's okay
but at least it'll change in an informed
way it's like discipline yourself in one
dimension see what happens well that's
exciting and I think that's something
that's open for everyone you can do that
I shouldn't say that because I don't
believe that I think you can find
yourself in a situation that's so dire
that you don't there's no escape from it
but that doesn't matter because the best
we have might not always work but it's
still the best we have and the fact that
it might not work doesn't mean we should
throw it away it's still the best we
have I mean everyone dies and so we fail
in some sense the fact that the symphony
ends doesn't mean that it wasn't worth
listening to responsibility
That's What Gives Life Meaning it's like
lift a load
then you can tolerate yourself right
because look at you're useless easily
hurt easily killed why should you have
any self-respect that's the story of the
Fall
pick something up and carry it make it
heavy enough so that you can think yeah
well useless as I am at least I could
move that from there to there well
what's really cool about that is that
when I talk to these crowds about this
the Man's eyes light up and that's very
like I've seen that phenomena because
I've been talking about this
mythological material for a long time
and I can see when I'm watching crowds
people you know their eyebrows lift
their eyes light up because I put
something together for them that's what
mythological stories do so I'm not
taking responsibility for that that's
what the stories do so I say the story
and people go click click click you know
when their eyes light up but this
responsibility thing that's a whole new
order of this is that young men are so
hungry for that it is unbelievable and
one of the things I've been talking to
some of the people who've been running
for the conservative leadership in
Canada and I've been talking to them
about well the difficulties they have
communicating with young people because
conservatives what the hell are they
going to sell to young people right
because being conservative is something
that happens when you're older they can
sell risk responsibility you need that
instinct for meaning too so and we
should get this real straight why do you
need it well you need it because life is
really really difficult right I mean
people have a rough time of it there's
plenty of suffering in life and everyone
is going to encounter it right there you
don't you know you learn this as a
clinical psychologist and you know this
generally you know unless you're an
extraordinarily fortunate person
um you don't have to talk to someone for
very long and and really talk to them
and get beneath the surface until you
find you know there's a tragedy or two
or three or ten lurking not very far
beneath the surface someone in the
family is very ill there's a childhood
history of extreme pathology alcoholism
somewhere in the family maybe a touch of
insanity someone has cancer you know
someone someone older relative is dying
there's financial trouble there's
economic trouble there's marital trouble
it's like life is trouble and now you
know that doesn't mean it's all trouble
but man it's trouble and sometimes it's
it's a lot of trouble and sometimes it's
so much trouble that you can you can
barely stand it and and you see that
because people you know people get
depressed and they commit suicide and
the reason they do that is because they
think not being is better than being and
that's quite the decision you know so
and and it's not that uncommon among
people who are depressed and so it's
it's a it's a very it's a very important
thing to consider and it and it isn't
just a matter of depression and suicide
that's bad enough but you know if you're
unhappy because your suffering has
pushed you past the point of your
ability to cope then there's all sorts
of other things that can happen to you
that aren't directed towards you you can
become cynical and you can become bitter
and you can become cruel and you can
become narcissistic and deceitful and
arrogant and and it's like everything's
for you and then you're out for Revenge
that's a nice one I don't know against
who but maybe everyone maybe even
including you because you're not happy
about the rule you've played in jail
generating your own misery I mean
there's a lot of Darkness underneath the
suffering and so and and that's that's
an ever-present existential danger for
human beings you know we're aware of the
future we're aware of our fragility
we're aware of our mortality it's
something that makes us truly unique
truly conscious in a way that no other
creature is and capable of things that
no other creature can do but also
bearing an unbelievably heavy
existential load were the only creatures
that have to always contend with the
fact that we're finite and that everyone
we know is in the same position that
allied with the suffering and so that's
there all the time and and you know even
even in in the brightest moments in some
sense you know in in Renaissance
paintings in still lifes they used to
put a Memento momento Mori often in the
in the still life like a skull somewhere
in the corner or sometimes sometimes in
in a very strange perspective so that
you could only see see the skull if you
were standing like right beside the
painting instead of dead on but the idea
was to always remember you know that
everything that exists is Tainted or
touched with the with the with the with
it with the taint of mortality and you
know that's rough but there's some
useful things in it it keeps you awake
and it keeps you focused if you're
careful but it also does indicate to you
if you think about it the necessity of
having a meaning in your life because
because
if it's true intrinsically that life has
this unbearable element of suffering
which seems to be completely in in what
would you say indisputable as far as I'm
concerned and it's worse than that too
because it's not just suffering it's
suffering contaminated with malevolence
right it's it's bad enough to have
something bad happen to you and it's
likely that that'll happen but it's even
worse for you to do it to yourself and
to know that you did it that's rough and
it's also extraordinarily rough to be
betrayed by someone else or you know
tyrannized by your own culture and so
and that's that's not just suffering
that's like unnecessary and pointless
suffering that's been directed at you by
something that wants that to happen and
so both of those are very very powerful
let's say archetypal forces suffering
and malevolence and we have to deal with
them at every level of reality and you
need something to you need something to
push back against that it's not optional
if that's the default position and I
think it's the default position like a
meaningless life isn't meaningless
it's suffering and malevolence
that's not good and and if that's acted
out you know that that's the other thing
if that's acted out and I've read the
accounts and the actions of people
who've
taken a very vicious turn into the
darkest parts of the underworld
consequence of their resentment and
their malevolence and then their desire
to make everything in the world suffer
for the outrage of its existence man I
mean that's how we turn things into hell
if you want to know why totalitarian
States take the brutal twists they take
and why people are motivated to do the
absolutely terrible things that they do
well that's why is that the suffering
and the malevolence that's intrinsic to
life overwhelms them and and they turn
and they turn in a very bad Direction
and then they make everything that's
already bad way worse and we're very
very inventive at such things and so
that's not good unless that's the path
you want that's a bad idea you need an
alternative and that's meaning human
consciousness is that faculty that
confronts potential itself I think
there's good neurological evidence for
this by the way for those of you who are
scientifically minded because uh we
build
circuits within us for habitual action
that we've practiced many times that
seem to run in a very deterministic
fashion and we are a strange combination
of deterministic and non-deterministic
as far as I can tell but what our
Consciousness seems to be for is to
encounter those things that we have not
yet encountered and those things that we
have not yet encountered seem to me to
be those things that have not yet been
brought into being and so you could say
that what our Consciousness is for is
for the encounter with potential you
know that our Consciousness is for the
it's not for the past it's not even for
the present
it's to transform the future into the
present and and really that that's what
our Consciousness does when you wake up
in the morning you have a new day ahead
of you and the day could take you in
very many directions and and the weeks
and the years all of that can take you
in very many directions and you have
some apprehension about what those
directions might be you have some
apprehension about what role your
choices might make in transforming that
potential into one form of actuality or
another I mean you certainly know that
there are Dreadful mistakes that you
might be very tempted to make that would
produce all manner of hell around you
and still be tempted to do it it seems
like it's sitting there right in front
of you as a possibility you also know
that you know you could haul yourself up
out of bed and attend to your duties and
do the sorts of things that you're
supposed to and said a few things right
that day and that week and that likely
things would at least not be worse and
they would probably be better and I I
believe that I do believe that I don't
understand how this can be the case I
don't understand how it is that
Consciousness Consciousness can function
in that way because I think to
understand that we would have to
understand what it means for the future
to be only potential rather than
actuality and who the hell understands
that I mean no one and then we'd have to
understand how it is that our conscious
choices and our conscious ethical
choices transform that potentiality into
actuality into reality into the present
and the past and we certainly
but we certainly act as if we believe
that that's what we do we upgrade
ourselves for example when we do a bad
job of it we're upset with our children
and those we love if we don't believe
that they're living up to their
potential we're guilty and ashamed when
we make choices that we feel are
inappropriate we understand to some
degree that the manner in which time
lays itself out has something to do with
the ethics of our choice and again I
would say that's a very deep idea I
think it's a I think it's I think it's
the most true idea I know it's very
emphasize that idea emphasized in
ancient religious stories such as those
that are outlined in Genesis or in
Genesis with its strange insistence that
you know God is that which
brings order out of chaos formless
potential generates the world out of
formless potential and that we're
somehow made in that image which which
seems to me to be the case and that the
proper way by the way to go about
acting in that image is to act in
relationship to the potential that
confronts you with truth and with
courage with careful articulation that's
the logos and that if you do that then
what you bring forth is is good when you
see people who are Noble in spite of
their suffering it is ennobling it is
uplifting right like really it is and
um and it's been striking to me too
people want to be encouraged in that
direction I mean part of the reason that
my lectures I would say have been
successful to the degree that they have
been is because people find them
encouraging and that actually seems to
work like it seems to be positive
because it is good news well it seems to
me I mean it isn't necessarily the case
that that would be the case you know
because it could have been that I would
have said encouraging things to people
there's more to you than meets the eye
and you're capable of more than you're
demanding of yourself and you know if
you took on your responsibility and face
the things that you're trying to avoid
that your life would be richer and
better and for you and for everyone
around you and the result of that could
have been that thousands of people would
come to me and say you know I gave that
a pretty good shot and it your advice is
really awful and everything is well
seriously like I took on that
responsibility it just bloody crushed me
and I'm way worse off than I was before
and everything's gone to hell around me
and like thanks a lot buddy and that not
it's not like that's a completely
incomprehensible possibility but that
doesn't seem to be what happens is what
generally happens is that young people
in particular but not only come to me
and say look I've been trying to take on
more responsibility and to face the
things I've been avoiding and everything
is way better it's like okay well isn't
that something to be onto something well
then you ask yourself well what's the
limit of that because that's the
religious question fundamentally is well
if you took on all the responsibility
you couldn't take on
then you faced everything that you
needed to face
what would you be like who would you be
and how would the world transform around
you and well if if the partial answer is
well if I do that a little bit things
get a fair bit better then the next
question might be well
what if you did that completely
and I don't think that's possible in
some sense right it's like you know
Perfection is a horizon that always
recedes but it isn't obvious to me
what the upper limit of that is and
certainly we do see people I mean Saints
right it's a Francis of assessment who
kind of pushed the limit and the
miraculous things happen around them
maybe in the literal sense and if not in
the literal sense close enough you know
for all intents and purposes and so
that's heartening I mean I
tear myself apart about this in many
ways because I think
perhaps it's possible to take on too
much responsibility and to crush
yourself as a consequence maybe that's a
sin of Pride who knows it's certainly
possible but my experience so far has
been that
when you see people bear their suffering
nobly
there's nothing in that but good
not something and then when you see
people take on more responsibility and
decide that they're going to aim up and
and
confront their suffering honestly and
forthrightly that their lives get better
and the lives of people around them get
better too
and so it's that's very strange as well
because it also means that the pathway
to less suffering
is through suffering
right and that's kind of that would be
hopeful if the world was constituted
that way it's like well there's
suffering how do you make it worse run
away
how do you make it better confront it
yeah but it's suffering it's like yeah
but it's there there it is it's right
there it's a precondition for existence
or something like that and it's like you
have something important to do as well
and you confront it and that's the
pathway to transcending it you look
where you think it's important to look
so I'll say that again you look where
you think it's important to look and
that means that well in a hierarchy of
importance is no different than a
hierarchy of value they're the same
thing a hierarchy of priority is the
same as a hierarchy of value and a
hierarchy of priority and a hierarchy
value and an ethic are all the same
thing right because you're going to look
at what you believe to be of cardinal
importance
otherwise you look well if you're
talking to someone and you look at their
feet
that's not going to be going very well
right first of all they're not going to
be very impressed with you because they
actually want you to look at their eyes
and that's because we communicate value
with our eyes and we do that directly
our eyes have even involved to do that
our eyes have whites around the iris so
that you can see where people Point them
because it's that important to know what
people think is important we see the
world through a structure of value
and I think that a huge part of that
structure of value is actually derived
from the entire set of texts entire set
of texts and their interrelationship
that have the biblical Corpus at their
base and so it seems to me that you I
think you can make a pretty damn strong
case
maybe on scientific grounds that you
can't see the world except through the
lens of the Bible
like literally you actually can't see it
now if it's not the Bible it might be
some other Corpus of texts but it might
be it isn't
and if it was well is it going to be a
corpus of text that we share because if
it isn't then we can't share our
perceptions and our values and if we
can't share those then we fight those
are the options right we either
stabilize our hierarchies of value in
some way that we agree upon mutually or
we fight that's or we're unbelievably
chaotic and confused and that'll just
produce fighting in any case and so
we have this structure of texts built
from the bottom up it's predicated on
the biblical narratives
and the texts exist in relationship to
those underlying narratives and derive a
fair bit of their meaning from the
meaning of the underlying narratives and
and vice versa you know
um
and so then the biblical is it possible
that biblical truth is the sort of truth
that is the precondition for truth
right because you think well it's
religious people make the claim people
of the Bible make the claim the Bible is
true well there's all sorts of different
kinds of truth that's that's an
interesting claim but it's not very
elaborated it's it's insufficient
um and you know often what happens to
Christians when they debate skilled
atheists like Richard Dawkins as they
treat the Bible like it's a scientific
theory and Dawkins just mops the floor
with them because it's actually not a
scientific theory compared to scientific
theories and so as soon as you go there
well it's like a scientific theory it's
like no it's not it's not and so does
that mean it's not true well it means
that if the only thing you think is true
is a scientific theory
but
I don't think that you can practice
science except within an ethical
framework that's not in itself science
and so it's possible that there is a
deeper truth than the scientific truth
which is the ethic that has to be their
a priority before you can even begin to
do science
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome pretend
more amazing rules from John ass rap
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
see you then a lot of athletes you know
have this term around the a game and
showing up and doing their absolute best
mentally emotionally physically
spiritually Etc and it got me thinking
about do you even know what your A game
is